these young men say they've run out of
options and that's why they've returned
to the streets
lebanon's economy has all but collapsed
we are hungry and tired
buying meat for our children is a dream
we are living a life of humiliation
there is no end in sight for the
financial meltdown the country needs
international financial assistance but
politicians are not reforming a state
riddled with corruption
the politicians are destroying us they
made us poor these young men don't have
jobs
the crisis is not new but it's got worse
because the government lifted its
subsidies on essential goods due to a
lack of foreign reserves
the fallout of the economic collapse has
left three-fourths of the population
poor and the united nations is warning
of even worse conditions if no solutions
are found
the local currency the lira continues to
lose its value against the dollar it's
affecting purchasing power while a
cash-strapped state has so far failed to
give the poor promised financial aid all
the while inflation is climbing
the dollar's exchange rate fluctuates
every hour that's why we don't put
prices on goods since they are adjusted
all the time
the crisis began in late 2019.
authorities used force to end the
nationwide protest movement and fought
about cabinet seats for more than a year
they formed the government in september
but it hasn't met for six weeks now
because of new political divisions
in lebanon we're not like any other
country where people going to the state
things will change because we're not
only
confronting a government we're
confronting a government which is backed
up with a very powerful militia i've
been playing around in the region which
is hezbollah
but many warn growing poverty could
change that
we don't have money to buy bread and
medicine for our sick family members we
can't cope with the situation
many have lost faith in a political
class blamed for ruining the economy
after decades of corruption but for now
there is little hope for change the road
to recovery appears blocked zen
al jazeera beirut